[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Human
vision is amazingly
beautiful and complex.
It all started
billions of years ago
when small organisms
developed a mutation that
made them sensitive to light.
Fast forward to today,
and there is an abundance
of life on the
planet which all have
very similar visual systems.
They include eyes
for capturing light,
receptors in the brain
for accessing it,
and a visual cortex
for processing it.
Genetically engineered
and balanced pieces
of a system which
help us do things
as simple as
appreciating a sunrise.
But this is really
just the beginning.
In the past 30 years, we've
made even more strides
to extending this amazing visual
ability, not just to ourselves,
but to machines as well.
The first type of
photographic camera
was invented around 1816 where a
small box held a piece of paper
coated with silver chloride.
When the shutter was
open, the silver chloride
would darken where it
was exposed to light.
Now, 200 years later, we have
much more advanced versions
of the system that can capture
photos right into digital form.
So we've been able to closely
mimic how the human eye can
capture light and color.
But it's turning out that
that was the easy part.
Understanding what's in the
photo is much more difficult.
Consider this picture.
My human brain can look
at it and immediately know
that it's a flower.
Our brains are
cheating since we've
got a couple million years
worth of evolutionary context
to help immediately
understand what this is.
But a computer doesn't
have that same advantage.
To an algorithm, the
image looks like this--
just a massive array of
integer values which represent
intensities across
the color spectrum.
There's no context here,
just a massive pile of data.
It turns out that the context is
the crux of getting algorithms
to understand image
content in the same way
that the human brain does.
And to make this work,
we use an algorithm
very similar to how the
human brain operates
using machine learning.
Machine learning allows
us to effectively train
the context for a data set
so that an algorithm can
understand what
all those numbers
in a specific organization
actually represent.
And what if we have images
that are difficult for a human
to classify?
Can machine learning
achieve better accuracy?
For example, let's take a look
at these images of sheep dogs
and mops where it's
pretty hard, even for us,
to differentiate
between the two.
With the machine
learning model, we
can take a bunch of images
of sheep dogs and mops,
and as long as we
feed it enough data,
it will eventually be
able to properly tell
the difference between the two.
Computer vision is taking on
increasingly complex challenges
and is seeing
accuracy that rivals
humans performing the same
image recognition tasks.
But like humans, these
models aren't perfect.
They do sometimes make mistakes.
The specific type of neural
network that accomplishes this
is called a convolutional
neural network or CNN.
CNNs work by breaking
an image down
into smaller groups of
pixels called a filter.
Each filter is a
matrix of pixels,
and the network does a
series of calculations
on these pixels comparing
them against pixels
in a specific pattern the
network is looking for.
In the first layer
of a CNN, it is
able to detect high-level
patterns like rough edges
and curves.
As the network performs
more convolutions,
it can begin to identify
specific objects
like faces and animals.
How does a CNN know
what to look for
and if its prediction
is accurate?
This is done through a large
amount of labeled training
data.
When the CNN starts, all of the
filter values are randomized.
As a result, its initial
predictions make little sense.
Each time the CNN
makes a prediction
against labeled data, it
uses an error function
to compare how close
its prediction was
to the image's actual label.
Based on this error
or loss function,
the CNN updates
its filter values
and starts the process again.
Ideally, each iteration performs
with slightly more accuracy.
What if instead of
analyzing a single image,
we want to analyze a video
using machine learning?
At its core, a video is just
a series of image frames.
To analyze a video we can build
on our CNN for image analysis.
In still images, we can use
CNNs to identify features.
But when we move
to video, things
get more difficult since
the items we're identifying
might change over time.
Or, more likely, there's context
between the video frames that's
highly important to labeling.
For example, if
there's a picture
of a half full
cardboard box, we might
want to label it packing a box
or unpacking a box depending
on the frames
before and after it.
This is where CNNs
come up lacking.
They can only take into
account spatial features,
the visual data in an image, but
can't handle temporal or time
features-- how a frame is
related to the one before it.
To address this issue, we have
to take the output of our CNN
and feed it into
another model which
can handle the temporal
nature of our videos.
This type of model is called
a recurrent neural network
or RNN.
While a CNN treats groups
of pixels independently,
an RNN can retain
information about what
it's already processed and use
that in its decision making.
RNNs can handle many types
of input and output data.
In this example of
classifying videos,
we train the RNN by passing
it a sequence of frame
descriptions-- empty box,
open box, closing box--
and finally, a label--
packing.
As the RNN processes
each sequence,
it uses a loss or error function
to compare its predicted output
with the correct label.
Then it adjusts the weights and
processes the sequence again
until it achieves
a higher accuracy.
The challenge of these
approaches to image and video
models, however,
is that the amount
of data we need to
truly mimic human vision
is incredibly large.
If we train our
model to recognize
this picture of a duck, as long
as we're given this one picture
with this lighting,
color, angle, and shape,
we can see that it's a duck.
But if you change any of that
or even just rotate the duck,
the algorithm might not
understand what it is anymore.
Now, this is the
big picture problem.
To get an algorithm to truly
understand and recognize
image content the way
the human brain does,
you need to feed it
incredibly large amounts
of data of millions of objects
across thousands of angles
all annotated and
properly defined.
The problem is so
big, that if you're
a small startup or a
company lean on funding,
there's just no resources
available for you to do that.
This is why technologies like
Google Cloud Vision and Video
can help.
Google digests and filters
millions of images and videos
to train these APIs.
We've trained a network to
extract all kinds of data
from images and video so
that your application doesn't
have to.
With just one REST
API request, we're
able to access a powerful
pre-trained model that
gives us all sorts of data.
Here's how easy it is to call
the Cloud Vision API with cURL.
I'll send this image
to the API, and here's
the response we get back.
Billions of years since the
evolution of our sense of sight
we found that computers
are on their way
to matching human vision, and
it's all available as an API.
If you'd like to know more
about the Cloud Vision and Video
APIs, check out their product
pages at the links here
to see how you can
easily add machine
learning to your application.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]